[Musik]
das podcast ist platin blm unicum fangen
wir sozusagen ernsthaft an
letzte woche habe ich ein paar themen
besprochen waren ethische themen und
dann kennen de in der fläche des geistes
votiere relevant sind und da war mein
fokus eher die frage was man heutzutage
der tiere in der philosophie sagt
natürlich wie ich letzte woche gesagt
habe könnte man ein ganzes semester lang
vorlesungen über diese frage halten also
fragen zur tieren in der jetzigen
philosophischen der partie unser
anliegen ist aber natürlich ein anderes
nämlich tiere in der geschichte der
philosophie zu besprechen
und sie haben in dem plan und oder auf
alles schon gesehen vielleicht sogar
voraus das ist sogar deswegen gekommen
dass ich mit einer sehr breiten
konstruktion der geschichte der
philosophie arbeiten werde
das heißt wir werden nicht nur
europäische klose wie betrachten sondern
auch nicht alle aber viele nicht
europäische philosophischen traditionen
islamische theologie wird sogar sehr
betont da werden zwei sitzungen dazu
widmen
und dann habe ich jeweils eine sitzung
zur indischen flüsse die klassischen
plus wie klassisch ist klassischer
chinesischer philosophie und sogar
amerikanische blues fi wenn sie nicht
wissen was was sie da darunter
vorstellen sondern müssen sie natürlich
nur warten dass der elefanten sitzung
wir fangen aber trotzdem mit sozusagen
traditionsgemäß mit den frühesten
griechen denken an nämlich die frau so
kritiker und was ich heute machen möchte
ist die post
beziehungsweise fragmente der physiker
votiere irgendwie auftauchen oder
relevant sind
dann werde ich danach platon beschreiben
da wird der eine haupt fokussierung auf
seinem dialog timos wegen wobei ich auch
andere dialoge zb der den beiden enden
werde
zuerst ein bisschen zu die post
insgesamt das betone ich immer gern
wie lange es her ist seit diese
philosophen gelebt haben
sie sind so alt dass erst die flosse das
wort für das ist liegen auch nicht gab
philosophie als terminus technicus wird
von platon eingeführt und taucht bei den
postkarten können nicht auf die also
wenn sie sich präsentiert hätten hätten
sie sich vielleicht verfolgt genannt
also weise und fühlen sich nicht
eingeschränkt nur philosophische themen
ist als sie ist bzw
haben sie überhaupt kein konzept über
das philosophische themen sind war die
weil sie eben dieses griechische wort
für klose 48 nicht zu verwenden
und daher ist praktische philosophie
irgendwie mit chinesische indische oder
afrikanisches land vergleichbar
das sind aus tradition wo das wort
philosophie noch nicht existiert oder
noch nicht existiert natürlich wird wird
es später in diesen ländern aus dem aus
den europäischen staaten eingeführt aber
wenn man zweifels dass man
philosophieren kann ohne das wort
philosophie zu haben muss man nichts
sagen aber es ist doch in indien löse
sie
man kann ja auch einfach sagen ja die
physiker denn allgemein als philosophen
anerkannt obwohl sie mit überflüssig wie
gesagt haben dann
also sie sind wie gesagt sehr lang her
also sei denn das wurde noch nicht
existiert hat und einfach schlicht und
einfach sehr sehr lange her da sage ich
immer gerne dass karl der große zu
alemannia bekannt ja also
frühmittelalterliche herrscher er ist
näher zu uns in der zeit aus für die
forscher kritiker das soll man wirkt das
ist das unglaublich aber es passt dem
der fall also um ein paar jahrhunderte
wie ich immer gerne sage alles was wir
aus der dieser zeit der antike haben
sind topf werke aus stein und politische
philosophie oder andere zur natur zum
beispiel holmes j und das kommt
natürlich nicht davon dass wir die texte
irgendwo begraben gefunden haben sondern
dass texte aus der antike immer wieder
mit der hand kopiert würde durch spät
die spätantike zeit und dann vor allem
in bezahlt und es ist aus eigentlich
ausschließlich durch byzantinische
handschriften dass wir ein ticket für
das sich im allgemeinen noch lesen
können zb plattform alle seine werke
sogar touristen sind auf griechisch
erhalten das sei erstaunlich wenn man
diese technik überlegt wie lange es her
ist man dass die würden buchstäblich das
ist alles geschrieben
in einer zeit wo wir wovon der gar nicht
wissen dass auf archäologie
trotzdem haben wir die texte weil sie
immer so geschätzt wurden dass
wissenschaftler und war ein schweizer
die mühe gegeben haben die texte zu
kopieren natürlich muss man das
regelmäßig machen weil die bücher werden
holz erfahren muss vorher feuchtigkeit
es gibt viele gründe warum texte dann
zugrunde gehen und nicht mehr fünf
pa sind im gegensatz dazu sind die post
kck überhaupt nichts erhalten
in mindestens wenn man als er halt wenn
man unter erhalten versteht dass wir die
bücher als ganze bücher besitzen
es gibt kein buch keine erhaltenes buch
von einem kroatischen würde sogar kainz
die also der erste philosoph bewegen wir
ganze bücher haben oder ganze texte erst
plattform bringe sie haben heute die
eule erst gesucht um athen zu werden
aber die vorsicht gegensatz zu platon
haben vorgehen nicht in athen gelebt die
erste post kritiker lebten an der küste
von der jetzigen türkei vor allem um die
der stabilität alvarez ist aus italien
passiert ist auch und so weiter also
diese texte die in ganz mittel mehr
geschrieben wurden sind nicht erhalten
wir kennen sie nur die durch zitate aus
späteren nicht nur für das außen sondern
halten im allgemeinen zum beispiel dass
dort wie ist also sollten dies berichtet
und zitiert aus dem demokratischen
philosophen ort nur um sie einfach zu
lieb zu widerlegen oder zu sagen ja zum
beispiel thales hatte eigentlich eine
gute idee aber das kann man das können
wir deutlich verbessern und dann geht er
weiter
bei einer sorte ist es eher selten dass
er wort wörtlich zitiert normalerweise
paraphrasierte oder fasst zusammen was
die erfolgskritische denke sagen haben
und ist manchmal sogar unklar
die wortwörtlich das ist also ob die
wortwahl wortwörtlich stammt oder von
dem fränkischen denke manchmal bei alles
ließ auch manchmal bei platon und auch
bei späteren autoren in der spätantike
vor allem
bei kirchenväter die physikalische denke
auch wieder legen wollten oder
kommentator dass dort die zum beispiel
im kickers haben wir sogar längere text
stücke wo es der krieg klar ist dass wir
die eigentliche texte haben
da muss man aber auch bedenken dass zum
beispiel pictures der das ist eine
spätantike kommentator sogar aus dem
sechsten jahrhundert nach christus also
mehr als ein jahrtausend nach die diesen
vor sie kritikern also erst wenn er ist
halt der größer als du die phase
kritiker zum beispiel ist dem klub boss
will diese texte zitieren gehen gerade
weil sie nicht mehr verfügbar sind oder
sehr schwer verfügbar sind zb paar
meinls sein gedicht zitiert er sehr
ausführlich weil er weiß dass es sehr
schwieriges kopieren von diesem text zu
finden
das wollte ja auch machen weil er als
heidnische philosoph das so sagen dass
philosophie reichtum der heimischen
kultur aufbewahren wollte in einer zeit
wo christentum schon die macht ergriffen
hatte es drückt 1 1 gegen christliches
projekt was er da macht und das ist ein
grund warum er diese vor strategie
zitiert also wenn man das überlegt ist
wirklich glücklich durch zufall und
viele zufälle sogar dass wir überhaupt
diese wirkte und ein testimonial uns
manchmal wenn wir glück haben sogar
fragmente also das heißt rückschritt
zitaten aus den pussy können überhaupt
besitzen und lesen können
also das ist ein sehr dankbar sein dass
das möglich ist sonst würde ich mit
klein anfangen ist okay was sagen die
forscher artikels für tiere eigentlich
relativ viel
vor allem wenn man
wenn man das betrachtet was ich gerade
gesagt habe dass es ein wunder ist dass
wir überhaupt was von den vorsichtigen
haben es noch wendiger dass wir relativ
über tiere sagen können und das in
verschiedenen kontexten es gibt
natürlich nicht natürlich aber es gibt
keine ist gar keine postkarte werke nur
zu diesem thema also heraklit zu tiere
das gibt es nichts was wir stattdessen
haben sind verschiedene fragmente und
testimonial votiere irgendwie erwähnt
werden manchmal ziemlich am passat oder
nur um einen anderen punkt zu machen
trotzdem können wir die vorzeitige
nützen um drei große themen zu
beobachten die uns durch das ganze
semester verfolgen werden oder
vielleicht verfolgen wir die themen aber
die begleiten uns durch das messer und
zwar diese drei themen das ein grund
warum ich mit den vorrichtungen anfangen
wollte weil man diese drei themen sehr
gut sogar bei den postkarten können
beobachten kann
die themen tauchen dann wieder in der
indischen tradition zb auch auf sollen
der afrikanischen prävention also man
man könnte vielleicht vorsichtig sagen
dass diese drei themen irgendwie
automatisch vorkommen wenn man
philosophisch libertäre reflektiert und
die erste zwei sind irgendwie irgendwie
offensichtlich und sind miteinander
verwandt oder sind sogar im gegen
gesetzte ideen über tiere einerseits und
vielleicht ist das das erste was
einfällt wenn man verlässlich wurden
sicher stellen was ich als erstes
geschrieben habe vielleicht ist das
erst etwas einfällt wenn man
philosophisch über pferde reflektiert
tier das sind keine menschen sind auch
keine steine oder pflanzen also bilden
eine gattung die mit uns verwandt ist
das ist der zweite punkt habe trotzdem
anders und wir können vielleicht dass
menschen verstehen wenn wir verstehen
was tiere sind oder beziehungsweise wir
können menschen besser verstehen wenn
wir verstehen wie menschen von tieren
oder was die menschen von tieren
unterscheidet zum beispiel denken oder
nationalität
eine these die sehr grundlegend für die
geschichte der fluss wie mindestens für
die europäische geschichte der fluss wie
ist natürlich dass tiere nicht rational
stand- und dass wir als rationale wesen
von tiere unterschieden unterschiedlich
sind und deswegen zum beispiel die
ethische behauptung dass menschen viel
mehr wertvoll sind als tiere bald ihre
keine nationalität besitzen wir schon zb
letzte woche gesehen dass manche
behaupten würden dass menschen personen
sind tiere nicht das ist sehr nah oder
wird vielleicht sogar dadurch begründet
durch die these dass nur menschen
nationalität besitzen nur personen oder
nur nationale wesen sind personen und
deswegen sind ihre irgendwie weniger
wertvoll oder vielleicht gar nicht
wertvoll
im vergleich zu menschen das natürlich
eine sehr genaue behauptung ist aber ein
beispiel von dieser allgemeiner
behauptung dieser allgemeinen behauptung
nämlich dass tiere und menschen
irgendwie grundsätzlich anders sind und
dass wir vielleicht wie gesagt die
menschheit besser verstehen wenn wir
verstehen
die fan menschen von tiere unterschieden
sind übrigens dafür vielleicht auf das
dass wir hier ein problem haben oder
vielleicht dass ein weiblicher einfach
mit dem schritt genommen würde nämlich
dass tiere einfach pauschal als eine
einheitliche gattung hier dann als masse
dann unter dem namen tier alle
eingeordnet werden
und das ist nicht so offensichtlich zum
beispiel scheint es dass affen mehr mit
menschen gemeinsam haben als mit zum
beispiel würmer wurden harfe mensch zu
werden ist der harfe ähnlicher dem wurm
oder dem menschen sich dem mensch
trotzdem sagen wir alle tiere von
insekten auf beschaffen und delfine und
die die ganz fortgeschrittene tiere die
eventhalle als tier betrachtet und man
könnte sich fragen warum wir werden
viele antwortest du dieser frage sehen
im laufe des semesters trotzdem kann man
mindestens sagen dass es das ist in der
alltäglichen sprache ein gott gegeben
hat führt ihr nämlich zorn
da davon haben wir andere wörter wie
zoologie natürlich studiert der tiere
und bahnbrücken mindestens festhalten
dass die griechen ein ein begriff und
ein konzept tier hatten genau wie wir
und das becken mit genau das ab was
unser wort tier abdeckt okay das die
erste große idee die von uns wichtig
sein wird zweite idee ist einfach das
gegenteil dazu nämlich dass menschen und
obwohl sie unterschiedlich sind auch
vieles gemeinsam haben zb zum beispiel
sind sie beide lebewesen des worts sohn
kommt sogar von den wert sehen das leben
das ist ein lebewesen oder ein lebendes
ist ein tier weiß nicht was die
etymologie von tier ist da eine
interessante frage aber das englische
wort perm ist auch sehr ähnlich also
anima seele es ist das passierte bis
tatsächlich aus dem lateinischen hier
ist wahrscheinlich einfach weiß das
niemand
germanistik das ist interessant
das würde das wäre ein leuten weil wie
wir sein werden wird ob wir das oft
sogar bei platin und dann bei von hatte
sollte dies auch gesagt dass tiere salz
bewegende wesen sind also bewegung ist
sehr nah an diesen begriff also nicht
nur das sehr nahe
also wenn man überlegt was ist diese
gattung von tier eine idee wäre ein tier
ist das was sich bewegen kann im
gegensatz zu pflanzen
ob das stimmt ist natürlich eine
interessante mein sonnenblumen können
sie drehen usw
trotzdem okay auf jeden fall die die
hatten das tier oder ein ein wort
dritten bitte bedeutend hier und sie
haben sie haben auch gesehen dass das
was tiere kennzeichnet auch beim
menschen vorkommt die wir sind auch
lebende lebewesen wir können auch
wahrnehmen wir können uns auch total
spontan bewegen können ziele verfolgen
alle sachen die auch tiere machen können
und von daher ist naheliegend zu sagen
das was allerdings bekanntlich sagt
nämlich dass man den mensch als eine
bestimmte art von tieren
definieren kann ein nationalist ihr also
ein tier das denken kann und die wir
haben deswegen sozusagen ein hin oder
her immer in der geschichte ihres wie
zwischen der idee wir es sind auch tiere
oder die tiere haben mit uns viel
gemeinsam und der idee und haben dann
haben wir die idee wir sind von tieren
sehr unterschiedliches wir sind anders
als tiere und dass die zwei ideen sind
fast immer präsent in philosophischen
haben ideen zu tieren
okay ein drittes thema was sollen schon
bei eine posse kritikern vorkommt ist
dass tiere ordentlich als beispiel
dienen können
für ein phänomen das auch allgemein in
der natur haupt haut nämlich dass tiere
vollkommen sind oder gut gestaltet die
sind harmonisch gebaut gut gebaut
das ist was man auf ezb der philosophie
der religion man sagt man manchmal dass
die welt gut gebaut ist oder gestaltet
ist dass man sprechen englisch von dem
design on demand also die ganze welt
seit das ein designer also ein gestalter
dann tätig war um diese welt schaffen
und das beispiel schlechthin dafür ist
einerseits der mensch natürlich aber
auch ein tier wenn man zum beispiel an
eine an eine gerade denkt wir denken an
den langen hals perfekt um blätter zu
erreichen ja also sehr gut durchdacht zu
sagen und niemand würde einen gerafften
anschauen denken oder es ist nur zufall
man man würde denken aber jemand hatte
das vor dass der dass die giraffe
sie soll ernähren sollen deswegen so
einen langen hals haben soll
oder vielleicht doch vielleicht niemand
doch sagen das ist durch zufall nämlich
ich habe erwartet dass sie alle tore
sagen nämlich daran ja oder auch im
petto quiz ein politischer denker den
man oft als sozusagen vorgänger
übernimmt er die sie geld
der gute gestaltung ist in der
geschichte wenn es um tiere geht sehr
oft präsent und führt auch als du sogar
so der weiteren idee dass das ganze
universum der kosmos hier ähnlich ist
oder sogar ein tier ist das werden wir
heute bei platon cent also dann wäre die
das universum ist ein lebender dein
lebewesen und hat andere lebewesen als
teile nämlich osten grafen affen würmer
und menschen
okay das sind drei leitthemen die ich
dann voraus erwähnen wollte
jetzt kommen wir so die fonds selbst und
fangen mit den frühesten musikern wie
gesagt an der küste von der jetzigen
türkei gelebt haben
vielleicht fange ich mit herber kritik
von herpes der den wollte ich erwähnen
nicht weil er so viele zusagen zu tier
tiere zusammen hat aber an er ist ein
sehr gutes beispiel für den ersten punkt
das heißt für den punkt dass tiere uns
irgendwie dagegen übersetzt sind also
ist sind
frenz und das kommt werden fragmenten
vor wo er darauf hinweisen will dass
tiere vielleicht eine andere sichtweise
auf die welt haben wie wir zum beispiel
sagt er
esel würden eher hass drei wellen als
gold er sagt er und dann habe ich andere
beispiele hier aufgeschrieben schweine
fühlen sich wohler im code als in
sauberem wasser
das ist natürlich ähnlich also wie vor
gold schweine ziehen code vor wasser hp
hat auch gesagt mehr
das sauberste und so bleibt das dass das
passte wasser für fische zwar zwang
barren heilsam
doch für menschen nicht zwingt bayern
verändern würde sie zu leben grund
verderblich also noch mal mehr das
sauberste und zugleich das verfahren
verfasste wasser für fische zwar in
halbendorf für menschen nicht hinhauen
verderblich okay was ist ja der punkt
natürlich nicht dass er eine psychologie
machen wollte sondern kommen diese tiere
vor um einen allgemeinen punkt zu machen
der für seine ganze klasse wie sehr
wichtig ist nämlich dass wir in der
natur oder in der in dem ganzen
universum immer beobachten das
entgegengesetzte eigenschaften zusammen
hoops zusammenkommen
also vielleicht das klarste beispiel ist
das eine ein pfarrer oder eine straße
ist der weg hinauf und gleichzeitig der
weg hinunter
also es kommt bei slovan kommt in welche
richtung man geht ja sie wenn sie ein
fragment aus hänner krieg kennen dann
wahrscheinlich das netz dem fluss dass
man nur dass das man nicht zweimal in
einen fluss hinein velten kann haben sie
wahrscheinlich gehört und sie haben
wahrscheinlich auch irgendwie mindestens
waage diät dass er dadurch zeigen wollte
dass alle ständig in veränderung ist
weil einfluss sich ständig verändert und
das ist nicht das gleiche
das gleiche wasser oder dergleichen
fluss ja das ist eine das ist eine
herauslösung von eine auslegung von
heraklit die wir schon bei platon finden
also herr doug reid ist der meister der
veränderung bewegen alles ist endlich in
bewegung panta rhei alles fließt ja aber
das ist haben mindestens meiner meinung
nach eine falsche interpretation
vielmehr wollte heraklit betonen dass
diese entgegengesetzte phänomene
zusammenkommen und dass wir als menschen
oft nur die eine seite sehen was wir
aber durch seine philosophie erkennen
können
erst die einheit die eigentlich als
unterliegt das land haben den lok aus
das ist ein kompliziertes wort kann zb
erzählung oder theorie oder wort heißen
in wörtern wie zoologie theologie
das urteil kommt von logos als eine lok
aus über tiere und um diese einheit zu
beweisen oder mindestens darauf zu
deuten hat er gut all diese beispiele
beispiele gebracht wo er sagt auch
ersten zwei entgegengesetzte phänomen
oder ideen und die kommen zusammen so
ich würde mit dem mit der straße oder
mit diesen zitaten über tiere
das betrifft auch den fragment zu dem
fluss weil also diese allgemeine version
die sie bleibt gehört haben dass es
falsch wahrscheinlich direkt die
ursprüngliche fassung hieß so was wie
über die die in denselben flüssen
steigen schließen immer andere gewässer
das heißt ein fluss verschiedene wasser
ja also ist einerseits dasselbe denkt
andererseits ein anderes denken selber
fluss anderes wasser also nochmal
entgegengesetzte eigenschaften die
zusammenkommen und das betrifft
natürlich unser die zitate zu tiere ist
schön hier hat schockwellen aus gold
oder schweine mögen court lieber als auf
das war so weiter die idee hier ist dass
selbst die idee dass irgend was wertvoll
ist ist eine ist eine feststellung die
mit der entgegengesetzten verstellung
zusammenkommen kann zum beispiel goldes
gleichzeitige wertvoll und wertlos es
kommt drauf an wer man ist als mensch
ist wertvoll ist als esel ist goldwert
los rugged usb wertvolle man könnte
diese idee in eine skeptische richtung
führen und das hat ein spiel später
geschenke 6 des imperiums gemacht sagt
das ist aus dem zweiten jahrhundert nach
christus und ist der wichtigste
spätantike skeptiker
er bringt in seinen werken eine ganze
reihe von skeptische argumente und eine
eine argumente oder vielleicht eine
arguments art die er gern verwendet ist
zu sagen dass die gleiche das eine
bestimmte eigenschaft von manchen
festgestellt wird nun von anderen
vereins wird klassisches beispiel das
kommt schon bei platten vor in den
dialog artikels manchmal sagt einer
dass ein wendt kalk ist der einer der
sagt dass das gleiche wendt warm ist und
diese verschiedenen sichtweisen auf die
dinge haben als folge laut sex dass man
nichts allgemeine oder nichts mit
sicherheit herstellen kann was oder
welche eigenschaften die dinge
tatsächlich haben zum beispiel ist der
wind kalt oder warm
es kommt darauf an wen man fragt sich
vielleicht eine relativ ismus und um
diesen punkt zu machen sagt sax das
unter handel tanzen nicht nur
verschiedene menschen r wenigen sondern
auch menschen und tiere und dann solche
beispiele sehr gut zum beispiel das gold
wertvoll
es kommt darauf an wenn man donald trump
fragt dann sagte er ja auf jeden fall
wenn man einen esel fragt ob er ist die
in gegenüberstellung vielleicht etwas
verschwommen
wobei es ist natürlich das tier der
demokratischen partei also von daher auf
jeden fall wenn man einen tier fragt
dann sagt ist ihr das gold wertlos ist
also dass das sind die diese beispiele
sind für hertha im allgemeinen ein
leugnen aber wir sind auch ein sehr
gutes beispiel von punkt 1 ein anderer
der früher für das so der tiere erwähnt
ist sehr offen ist und er ist wieder ein
beispiel von einem philosoph der tiere
erwähnt um zu betonen dass sie sozusagen
eine andere gattung bilden als die
menschen und hier ist der es das beste
fragment ein zitat von ihm über
griechische region
das ist allgemein der fall dass die post
hier denke oft ziemlich kritisch der
teils in einem griechischen regierung
gegenüber waren
und wenn ist es der das erste beispiel
davon und verspottet versetzen alle
ideen über die gotte also dass die gotte
praktischen mächtige menschen sind die
kämpfen können sich verlieben können
sich betriebe sich gegenseite drücken
kann also weiter bleibt das alles
abgelehnt und gesagt dass gott also er
hat ein sozusagen ein philosophen gott
der einst ist und der nur denkt die
ganze theorie müssen wir nicht
diskutieren aber seine sein verständnis
über gott war sehr sehr anders als das
was wir zum beispiel bei homer oder hier
finden
und er kritisiert has not und hunger
namentlich übrigens kritisierte auch
heraklit und
sagt dass ihre vorstellungen über region
lächerlich sind und um diesen punkt zu
machen sagte er folgendes wenn die
ochsen und löwen handy hätten oder
morgen könnten mit ihren händen und
werke bilden wie die menschen so würden
die rosse ross ähnliche dioxinähnliche
göttergestalten malen und solche körper
bilden wie jede art gerade selbst das
aussehen hätte
wer also erst der punkt wenn ein löwe
überlegt in der lage werde sich
überlegen wie es geschafft gott aus der
löwenzahn wie ein gott heutzutage sehr
wohl gehört ist wie ein löwe
ja aber noch besser vielleicht ein
größerer löwe mit ganz schöne menge die
ich in der aufnahme haben werde und
wasser und natürlich ist ein punkt hier
die allgemeine idee oder die damals
gängige idee dass gott eigentlich wie
menschen sind er wollte dass sich
darüber lächerlich machen wenn man zum
beispiel an das gemälde an die in einem
dach von der systemische kapelle denkt
da ist gott buchstäblich als ein mensch
vorgestellt das genau was innovativ das
ist jüngst in auch fern ist denn auch
das ist ein schüler von leitern muss man
immer vorsichtig sein
ich wusste genau was als innovativ
ablehnen werden
andererseits gibt es einen zweiten
fragment der den gleichen punkt macht
aber mit menschen als er hat gesagt die
äthiopien behaupten jede götter seien
schwarz und stumpf nasic die trucker
blauäugig und rothaarig also das ist ein
punkt den er entweder mit mensch und
tier machen kann oder mit zusammen unter
arten von menschen
man kann nämlich afrikanische menschen
und europäischen menschen oder das
südafrikanische menschen und
nordeuropäischen menschen also
vielleicht soll man nicht so viel
gewicht darauf legen dass er tiere als
beispiel nimmt aber trotzdem sieht man
das wenn er wenn er habe nein auf ein
beispiel kommen will wie man aus sehr
verschiedenen sichtweisen irgendwas
betrachten kann ist wie naheliegend
theoretisch ist genau wie wir unter
diesem hessen.de erwarten würden
übrigens ein offenes haben wir auch ein
erstes beispiel von einem allgemeinen
phänomen was bei npd es dann als ein
gipfel erreichen wird nämlich dass
manche fonds ii kg schied denke erstens
im allgemeinen wissenschaftliche
interessen hatten also mathematik physik
kosmologie und so weiter aber auch solo
gi und haben dann theorien entwickelt
wie tiere gebaut sind dann stichwort
punkt 3 oder einfach wissenschaftliche
untersuchen zu nichtmenschliche tiere
unternommen haben und für diese ganz
früh vor sich hat wir haben mit sehr
vielen diese richtung
trotzdem haben wir eine sehr interessant
interessant bericht die büchsen offen
ist nämlich das folgende hin offen ist
der meinung es finde eine mischung der
erde mit dem mehr starts und die erde
werde mit der zeit von feuchten
aufgelöst dafür erklärte die
überzeugende beweise zu haben
im landesinnern und im gebirge app
findet man muscheln und in syracuse sagt
er würden in den steinbrüchen abdrücke
eines sich und von jeder stamm gefunden
diese dinge sind wie er sagt entstanden
alles vor langer zeit alles verschlammt
gewesen sei und er hat dort sein schlamm
durch trocken fest geworden sehr
einfallsreich natürlich und natürlich
sogar richtig das ist das ist schön zu
sehen dass das ist konnte den ersten
berichten oder setzen überhaupt erst der
europäischen wissenschaft zu irgendwas
das genau richtig wissenschaft ist doch
leicht
also das ist natürlich keine tiefe
erklärung über die natur der tiere oder
sowas aber ich fand es sehr interessant
zu erwähnen dass tiere hier vorkommen in
dieser wissens ab achtung und was
vielleicht hier auch nicht irrelevant
ist werde die implizite annahme dass die
tiere die vor langer zeit existiert
haben
genauso sind wie die tiere jetzt und wie
wir sehen weil diese antike fische sind
eigentlich nur fische und die wir finden
sie diese versteinert im gebirge wie sie
fossilien sind genau wie fische jetzt
anscheinend wie wir es eng werden auch
in bayern das zeugnis ist das ein
kontroverses thema also die frage ob die
tiere mit der zeit verwandten oder ob
sie immer dasselbe sind
allerdings ist der ansicht dass
tierarten ewig sind und nicht
veränderlich sind andere philosophen aus
der antike auch andere forscher teilen
diese meinung nicht okay es gibt auch
aber frühere griechische musikalische
theorien sogar zu der entstehung von
tieren und dafür ist ein gutes beispiel
ein anderer politischer philosoph namens
an absender
und er hatte eine ein schönes eine
schöne theorie über die ursprüngliche
generation heutzutage wir wissen die
tiere sich fortpflanzen das werde ich
nichts ist ein bisschen früh am tage um
das detailliert zu beschreiben aber sie
wissen schon wie fortsetzung grob wissen
sie wie das funktioniert sogar die
jungen menschen und das nicht aber die
dickmann könnte die frage stellen ob die
woher kommentiere aber ursprung ist eine
idee wer das sagen
nirgendwo her es gab immer tiere und
zwar die tiere die jetzt existieren
das alles bot ließ aber die post hatte
ich wieder denker ist neigen eher dazu
ist es haben dass wir irgendwie irgend
ein kosmisches prozess haben wodurch
tiere irgendwie entstehen
dafür ist das erste beispiel so weit wie
ich weiß ein maximum an der cooler name
auch ein maximum an dorf als falls sie
noch jung genug sind um selbst
fortzupflanzen und sie einen sohn haben
würde ich sehr empfehlen dass sie
überlegen den sonax ihm anders nennen
wenn sie sich vorher kommt in die
grundschule sagt ich bin ein nazi
der erste mann oder dass ein noch mal
ein bericht über ihn er stellt sie sich
vor dass aus wasser und erde die herbert
bäume fische oder jedenfalls lebewesen
entstanden sind
die den fischen sehr ähnlich waren ihnen
hätten sich die menschen entwickelt im
inneren wie embryonen bis zur reife
festgehalten
dann erst seien jene aufgeplatzt und es
seien aus ihnen männer und frauen heraus
gekommen die sich bereits seit ernähren
konnten ja das nenne ich wissen schafft
man sich hier übrigens nehmen wir merken
wie ungenau
diese berechtigen manchmal sind bei der
der betrachter sagt die wahren fische
oder jedenfalls lebewesen die den
fischen ähnlich waren
man sieht dass das es schon unklar
geworden ist genau was er sagen wollte
aber die idee ist durch ein natürliches
prozess entstehen fische und da
rauskommen menschen und die die werden
irgendwie in dem in den innereien der
fische irgendwie gekocht oder
vorbereitet sehr schöne idee und was man
vielleicht hier also da könnte man
mehrere es dass du sagen was für uns
interessant ist erstens scheint er ist
davon auszugehen dass fische bleibt
tiere in spam allgemeinen einfacher sind
als menschen deswegen kann man einen
fisch durch ein krasses physisches
prozess unmittelbar produzieren weil man
braucht zwei schritte um menschen zu
erreichen
man kann einfach feuchte und wärme
zusammenbringen und daraus zu machen und
deswegen sind durch die enorme leben
immer noch in dieser feuchte erde im
wasser aber um menschen zu machen
braucht man sozusagen einen organischen
zusammenhang also man könnte nie
menschen einfach aus erde und wasser
produzieren man kann menschen noch als
anderen
evesen produzieren nehme diese einfachen
lebewesen fische also hier sind wir
wieder bei punkt eins wir sind
fortgeschrittene
das sind beeindruckende deswegen ist es
schwieriger und zu produzieren als
frische produzieren
andererseits sind wir auch bei teil 2.2
weil fische und wir sehr eng verwandt
sind die sind sogar unsere mutter weil
wir bekommen aus den innereien der
fische der fische ursprung interessenten
er hat übrigens auch gesagt der merkt
der mensch seit anfang ist einem anderen
label wesen ähnlich gewesen nämlich
einen fisch also diese ursprüngliche
menschen waren wahrscheinlich irgendwie
weil sie aus bisher entstanden sind
vielleicht könnte man hier sogar eine
gewisse neigung seiner evolutionstheorie
erkennen uns bevor wir die frühe der
denker dann verlassen wollte ich auch
ein examen ist erwähnen nicht
miteinanders zu verwechseln natürlich
wobei wenn sie zweifelsohne hätten bei
maximalen der hund einer extremen ist
das wäre schon was ja ein maximaler ich
meine texte - hör auf es war ein
politischer denker der alles durch ein
prinzip erklären wollte dass es das
kommt auch oft vorbei denn falls
traktoren wie alles ließ auch betont
dass sie oft einen ein prinzip aussuchen
was wodurch sie alles erklären können
zum beispiel wasser bei thales oder luft
bei antenne ist und ein ex minister
das ab heran dass das unbegrenzte oder
das nicht mitbestimmte gerne also kein
physisches prinzip bleibt sondern ein
abstraktes prinzip und alexa minis hat
was interessantes gesagt was punkt für
punkt 3 relevant ist wird gesagt wie
unsere seele die luft ist und uns
beherrschen zusammenhält so umfasst auch
den ganzen kosmos atem und luft sich
hier wird den mensch mit dem ganzen
kosmos verglichen
das ist natürlich einen an ein vorschlag
was der ort in der geschichte der tour
sieg vorkommt dass der mensch ein
sogenannter mikrokosmos ist also ein
kleiner kosmos wurde man könnte sagen
dass der kosmos ein makro am korpus ist
ein großer mensch und sie könnten
natürlich sagen hey das hat gar nichts
mit ihr zu tun mit tieren zu tun aber da
würde ich trotzdem bemerkten dass der
die ähnlichkeit zwischen kosmos und
mensch liegt daran dass luft und
zusammenhält und den kosmos weil wir
atmen können und also luft hält uns
zusammen die den kosmos wie so oft den
kosmos zusammen
nicht ganz klar aber vielleicht weil wir
erde himmel haben und zwischen luft er
hält alles zusammen und das ist
plausibel aber die tatsache dass wir
atmen ist natürlich nichts was menschen
eigenes militär können aufatmen also ich
würde sagen dass diese beobachtung
wahrscheinlich allgemein eine haben ein
transfer von tierarten so kosmos ist das
ist vielleicht unter den ersten beispiel
wenn ich das erste beispiel voran einem
fragments oder von einem denker der
behaupten will
das dass der kosmos ähnliches zu einem
lebewesen und das noch mal werden wir
öfters in unserer geschichte sehen
okay vielleicht habe ich da pause was
jemand fragen hat sie am ende wieder
eine chance haben dann gehen wir
unmittelbar so die pizza oder ja
wahrscheinlich haben sie deswegen keine
fragen gestellt weil sie wollten
unbedingt sein was die serie sagen das
ist eine feine schule sind natürlich
dafür bekannt dass sie des cms und
mathematik verstehen wollten dass sie
verschiedene religiöse rituale ian
hutton dass sie verschiedene regelungen
eingehalten haben zb dass man manche
sachen nicht essen wohnen dürfte man
nicht essen und fleisch sind die erste
vegetarier und das ist schon interessant
für uns also die wahrscheinlich das
erste beispiel in der geschichte der
flüsse wo wir keine eine ein gesetz oder
eine ethische regelung gegen tier konsum
finden und man fragt sich warum
und die antwort scheint auf der hand zu
liegen nämlich dass die partei wäre ja
auch bekanntlich an wiedergeburt der
glaubt haben oder 20 nationen
das kann von einem menschen körper zu
einem anderen menschen bedeuten sind
durch mit pythagoras selbst konnte an
seine früheren leben erinnern könnte
sich daran erinnern wer er war und in
diesem frühjahr
neben war er auch mensch zum beispiel
mein leben war eine prostituierte
interessanterweise aber er hat nicht
gesagt die war vorher ein huhn oder
einheit achsel oder des hungers sich an
menschliche leben erinnern können
trotzdem und habe trotzdem gibt es auch
dafür belege dass die kategorie
akzeptiert haben dass die seele die sich
jetzt in einem mensch befindet
vielleicht vorher in einem in den körper
eines tieres war zum beispiel haben wir
den spätantiken für das portfolio der
später für uns sehr wichtig sein wird
möglich wäre sogar eine ganze vorlesung
seriös halten weil er es so spannend ist
über für unser thema juli sagen er ist
mit abstand der interessanteste
griechische denker für philosophie die
arterien und in dem werk den wir dann
später besprechen wird werden sagt er
das für die peta die seele sich in
andere arten von lebewesen verwandeln
kann also verwendet hier das wort
genozid oder gar tom also die idee hier
ist dass die das lebewesen in
verschiedenen gattungen oder arten
vorkommen und das die seele so sagen so
beliebig von einer anderen übergehen
kann
also wenn wir sterben werden wir im
nächsten leben vielleicht kuhn oder
eidechsen oder rolle und in letzten male
wollen wir vielleicht weil er oder high
tech oder oder wasser und es ist relativ
klar
von daher soll um die pedale was die
gegen haben könnten wenn man tiere ist
wurde wenn man fleisch ist nämlich dass
man vielleicht einen ehemaligen einen
ehemaligen mensch ist und dass wir
kannibalismus schlecht wobei sie das
nicht genau sagen
wir haben ein bericht über peter gross
was sehr interessant ist und kommt sogar
von zehn opfern ist den für das ding ich
keinem anfang erwähnt habe
ich habe gesagt er erwähnt andere
philosophen unter anderem gesagt peter
groß beziehungsweise die das ist ein
billigt wo er sagt dass ein weißer mann
folgendes gesagt hat aber ein später
eines später der quelle behauptet dass
er hier pythagoras meint in der sehr
sehr wahrscheinlich weil es nur den
markt werden dass ein philosoph es der
dafür bekannt ist dass er ein video
gebäudeteil creation glaubt und die
geschichte ist ganz niedlich oder
vielleicht traurig und niedlich
gleichzeitig daher ist dass ich die
geschichte als vier tages an einem fast
als er so wahrscheinlich pythagoras an
einem kleinen hündchen vorbeiging
welches gerade gequält wurde
manche könnten deutlich gefeilt wurde in
einem kleinen hündin vorbeiging welches
gerade gefällt wurde soll er folgendes
gesagt haben
hör auf mit deinem schlagen denn es ja
die seele eines freundes die ich
erkannte wie ich ihre stimme hörte
also er könnte also dass das hühnchen
gewählt oder hier vereint hat das klingt
genau wie mein kumpel klar
ich weiß nicht ob sie alle freunde haben
die männchen können aber er hatte er
halte einen sk die diese idee dass sie
vier tage das irgendwie tiere verstehen
konnte euro emittieren kommunizieren
konnte wird es auch im handeln quellen
belegt es gibt es gibt geschichten über
ihn und bei manchen legenden kommt es
vor dass er sich mit einem tier
unterhält und sogar seine philosophie an
dem tier weitergibt oder lehrt belehrt
und in einem beispiel überzeugte ein bär
dass der berg an keine andere tiere
gewalt ausüben sollte das ist und dass
es doppelt interessant erstens weil wir
hier wieder an jede haben dass man
gewalt gegen tiere vermeiden soll auch
tiere sollen verbreiten gewalt gegen
tiere ausüben wenn dann werden sie dazu
bringen können das zu vermeiden und der
bär es irgendwie menschen ihn nicht
genug dass die tagung dass mit ihnen
kommunizieren kann also targo realismus
ist das beispiel schlechthin aus der
frühen später ist das frühen antike für
punkt zwei tiere sind menschen englisch
beziehungsweise sie sind sogar menschen
oder sie ist sie haben zählen die vorher
menschen waren und vielleicht das beim
nächsten mal wieder menschen werden
also von daher könnte man vielleicht
sogar sagen dass die pedalerie diese
scharfe grenze zwischen mensch und tier
abschaffen bäumen die wollen sagen nein
es gibt nur sälen wurde ob eine seele im
moment sich in einem mensch körper
befindet oder einem tier körper ist
eigentlich ohne belang ist mir nur
zufall
und deswegen könnte man digital wäre er
vielleicht als alliierte denke nehmen
für die jetzige denke die diese scharfe
grenzen zwischen menschen und tiere
nicht akzeptieren wollen
also kaffee mensch ist alles sehr
verschwommen was ist ein tier was ist
ein mensch ist irgendwie alles dasselbe
wir sind doch alle lebewesen am ende
eine ganze große familie mit zwei
familien mensch und tier und terrorismus
scheint sehr stark in diese richtung zu
gehen
andererseits ist es auch bei dieser
patagonischen theorie der integration
wichtig dass das ist wirklich das ist
für uns interessant ist ob unsere seele
in einem mensch körper landet oder in
einem tierkörper und das phänomen das
angebliche phänomen dass menschen zählen
im tierkörper dann eintreten können und
umgekehrt könnte man so interpretieren
dass das irgendwie als strafe gemeint
ist also sehen wir uns in denen jetzigen
leben
schlecht benehmen werden wir dadurch
bestraft würde dafür bestraft dadurch
dass wir beim nächsten leben als tiere
geboren werden und vielleicht sogar als
schlechte tiere als wärme oder hunde
oder sage immer man nehmen wir als ein
beispiel von einem fan nicht anfechten
ich wollte nicht an gut gut angesehen
und wenn das die wenn das der fall ist
wenn die kategorie wirklich sagen wollen
dass menschen dadurch bestraft werden
dass sie tiere werden dann ist es auch
der fall dass es entscheidend ist ob man
einen mensch körper hat oder im
tierkörper hat das ist die belohnung
oder bestrafung für das was man vorher
gemacht hat allerdings ist nicht ganz
klar ob die sie habe diese terry mit
strache sie tun hat denn wir erstaunlich
wenig belege dafür haben und man
vielleicht eine andere interpretation
geben könnte nämlich dass das wir nicht
unbedingt
das dass wir im nächsten leben nicht
unbedingt den körper bekommen den wir
verdient haben sondern einfach den
nächsten körper der saison an der reihe
ist
und das können wir auch aus einer
passage bei hätte tod nehmen weil erst
sagt was interessantes über die ganze
theorie des wiedergeburt erstens dass
das alles aus ägypten kam also dass die
theorie ursprünglich aus afrika stammt
seine ein vorgeschmack afrikanischen
profi seine afrikanische ägyptische
theorie die von den trägern übernommen
würde das heißt es übrigens eine
behauptung die ziemlich oft vorkommt
wenn es um korsika ticker geht dass sie
irgendwie er die ideen aus ägypten
genommen haben zum beispiel thales hat
angeblich in ägypten mathematik gelernt
aber in diesem fall geht es darum dass
die theorie von wiedergeburt
ursprünglich skeptisch ist und dass es
dieser theorie nach der fall ist das die
seele wie er sagt sich jetzt in einem
neuen kleider kleidet also hier ist die
seele wie es fast wie die zelle ist der
mensch unser körper ist ein gewand
kleidet sich in einen neuen körper und
muss dann durch alle hier hatten durch
arbeiten die reihe nach vielleicht dass
die zelle dann in einem mensch körper
landet also wenn das der fall ist haben
sollen wir uns wir sollen alle sehr
glücklich sein
nicht nur weil wir die fragmente der
vorsichtige lesen können was zu
verlassen sondern auch wegen des super
ist dass wir alle im moment im team
mensch körper sind das sollen wir
wirklich schätzen und ausnutzen weil
vielleicht vielleicht werden wir alle
für die nächsten 10.000 jahre 2000 jahre
als tiere leben müssen und nicht als
menschen das ist so das ist unsere
chance es gut dass sie alle philosophie
machen weil das natürlich die richtige
wahl sind sie nutzen ihre zeit sehr gut
dadurch dass sie hier sind
ok also wenn wenn die theorie so war
also nicht dass man mit einem tierkörper
bestraft wird sondern dass man einfach
die reihe nach alle körper bekommt die
man haben kann was denn dann
die begründung dafür was war das kann
man dadurch erreichen durch diese
theorie eine interessante vermutet werde
dass man dadurch erreicht dass man alle
mögliche erfahrungen gemacht hat und
hier können wir jetzt so dazu so herr
krieg gehen die diese beobachtung dass
verschiedene tiere wahrscheinlich
verschiedene sichtweisen auf die welt
haben zum beispiel wir können wir können
wahrscheinlich gar nicht verstehen wie
ist es lieber im kot zulegen als in
sauberem wasser oder gold als weniger
wertvoll zu betrachten als streu aber
wenn wir als esel oder schwein leben
können oder könnten dann würden
für diese sichtweise auch gehabt haben
und wenn wir alle tiere schon wenn wir
schon als alle tiere geboren waren
würden wir dieses gesamte wissen oder
würden wir alle diese sichtweise auf die
welt gehabt haben und wir werden so
sagen halt ist das ist eine sehr
ambitionierte auslegung dieser idee habe
oder diese theorie aber es irgendwie in
einigen vor allem wegen dem was wir bei
empedokles im paddock es ist der
interessanteste vorsichtiger vor unser
thema weil er viele tiere gesagt hat
dass mit zum teil wahrscheinlich daran
dass wir einfach mehr von dem paddock
ließ haben heißt von den meisten große
partikel haben sehr ausführliche zitate
oder reste von seinem gedicht oder sogar
zwei geräte und möglich ist auch
interessant weil wir vor etwa 20 jahren
wir also man hat in frankreich paar neue
fragmente eines seiner werke gefunden in
einer bibliothek in straßburg und dieses
so genannte fast salzburg fragments hat
dann die menge von taxco empedokles
deutlich erhöht der wissenschaftler der
das ediert und kommentiert hat ist an
der lmu ist mein kollege mein kollege
oliver krämer basie dass er hier in der
hand philologie also erst der welt
führende experte für in paris ok auf
jeden fall hempel unter anderem
vielleicht weil wir einfach so viel text
haben aber auch sicherlich weil er aus
verschiedenen gründen an tiere
interessiert war hat relativ viel zu
sagen über tiere und dazu gehört dass er
auch an diese video gewürzt handy
geglaubt hat und
behauptet behauptete dass er sich an
seine früheren leben erinnern konnte in
seinem fall habe hat er sich daran
erinnern können dass er vorher tier war
sehr schön
er sagt weil er sagte ich bin schon ein
kabel gewesen und ein mädchen ein busch
und einen vogel wurden ein aus dem meer
springen der wandernde fische dass sein
zitat er sein die dichten schön oder
sollte es noch mal vorlesen
ich bin schon ein knabe gewesen und ein
mädchen ein busch und einen vogel und
ein haus tümler springende wandernder
fisch das erste was für mich hier
auffällig ist dass er auch eine pflanze
war er war ein busch für ihn also
scheint es dass die video geburts
theorie trägt als integrations theorie
sogar alle lebewesen einschließt selbst
die pflanzen also alles was laid kann
man werden die seele geht von einem
gestalt zum nächsten manchmal ist es
eine pflanze manchmal ein tier manchmal
ein eine frage manchmal ein mann
man hat alles sozusagen erlebt und das
ist sehr wahrscheinlich sein punkt also
was er was im paddock riss mindestens
unter der theorie verstehen wollte war
genau das dass er die dass er die das
volle maß an weisheit rollenverständnis
erreicht hatte weil er all diese
verschiedenen lebewesen schon war also
dass es interessant auch interessant ist
dass er sehr deutlich erklärt was die
verbindung zwischen video geburts werde
erst und das bei meiden von
fleischkonsum denn es eine andere
passage bei ihm gibt wo er das sehr
wichtige praxis
denn der praktischen gesellschaft
nämlich ihr opfer kritisiert hat es ist
vielleicht dass er würde anscheinend
würde er als exil als seiner heimatstadt
geschäft vielleicht weil er dieses
praxis von tier opfer angegriffen hat
das war es ist wirklich sehr wichtig in
der griechischen gesellschaft war basis
der ganzen religion wie wir später sehen
werden hat piräus das auch abgelenkt
gelernt das ging übrigens so dass man
das tier geschlachtet hat und dann
gebraten oder gekocht und dann haben die
menschen die an der hand in hand der
feier teilgenommen haben
sie haben alle fleisch gegessen und ein
teil des fleisches und den knochen wurde
verbrannt und das war für die götter
also die hand den brauch genommen und
die anwesende menschen haben das fleisch
gegessen und im paddock es ist sehr
dagegen und das ist wie die geschichte
mit dem hündchen bei peters er war
deswegen dagegen dass man vielleicht aus
versehen einen mensch ist und nicht nur
irgendeinen mensch sondern einen ganz
bestimmten mensch nämlich zb dein
großvater sein zitat der vater hebt den
eigenen sohn auf das sich in seiner
eigenen gestalt beendet hat schlachtet
ihn und babe dazu
der blinde tor den sohn der herzzellen
klagt und ihn anfleht während er hoffe
er aber taub gegen die schreie schlachte
team und bereitet im haus ein hübsches
mal in derselben weise ergreift der sohn
den vater und packen die kinder die
mutter sie haben ihnen das leben und
verspeisen das fleisch ihrer leiden also
was er hier sicher vorstand ist das
einmal zum beispiel ein schaf
geschlachtet als tier hoffe er weiß aber
nicht dass dieses schaf sein gestorbener
sohn erst dies
die zelle von dem song ist jetzt im
körper des schafes und herzschlag gesang
deswegen seinem sohn und ist ihn auf
sehr schlecht oder eben die mutter ihr
kennt oder das kind der mutter die die
großvater und großmutter und so weiter
und so fort
sie sehen den punkt also dass das ist
würde ich sagen ein sehr überzeugender
grund vegetarier zu sein
also wenn es sie wirklich meinen das
können wir nicht ausschließen ja also
wenn sie selbst wenn sie denken okay ist
wahrscheinlich nur 0,01 prozent
wahrscheinlich dass dieses tier
mein großvater war vielleicht so meint
rassisten er nur haben immer sicher
gehen und das sind ja nicht essen
aber an was ich interessant finde und
ich wollte darauf aufmerksam keit
anziehen
die die begründung die wir hier für
vegetarismus bekommen als bei tages und
haustiere bei empedokles ist nichts zum
beispiel dass tiere wertvoll sind oder
rechte haben und deswegen sollen wir sie
nicht essen
die begründung ist vielleicht hast du
pech und das tier ist mit dir ist nicht
nur ein vorheriger menschen sondern ein
mensch der sein freund war oder dein
verwandter ist und natürlich könnte mein
gepäck haben das wäre vielleicht eine
ausreichende grund kein fleisch zu essen
ist aber sehr weit von den gründen die
wir haben normalerweise kein fleisch zu
lassen und ist irgendwie nicht einmal
eine ethische theorie weil das hat
nichts mit tiere im allgemeinen zu tun
das hat nur damit zu tun dass man die
verwandte und freunde nicht essen soll
und es ist natürlich war im allgemeinen
in der regel lehnen wir das auch ab aber
es aber erscheint sie zitieren dass die
oder ist sie implizieren dass wenn wir
irgendwie feststellen könnten vielleicht
sagt ein toaster keine sorge diese
dieser ist dieses schaf ist nicht mit
ihr verwandt
dann können wir das schaf essen ja nicht
was wir wollen in einer tätig das andere
was im paddock über tiere gesagt hat was
interessant ist geht zurück zu dem was
ich vorher über ein maximaler gesagt
habe dass mit also wo die menschen aus
den fischen da kommen vorkommen
er hat katie price hat eine sehr
ambitionierte kosmologische theorie
wonach die vier elemente
er ist übrigens der erste philosoph in
der griechischen passion der diese vier
elemente anerkannt feuer erde wasser
luft und seiner meinung nach ist er hat
eine kosmologie wo folgendes passiert
die vier elemente sind eine homogene ist
werde die sind alle durch und durch
gemischt damit alles perfekt im
gleichgewicht ist dann mit der zeit
durchzogen wer wird dieses werde
auseinander gelegt und da entstehen
verschiedene mischungen die dann
verschiedene zierteile werden
wir kommen da hinein also könnt ihr
kommen zurück dann kommen diese teile
zusammen bilden tiere und menschen
und dann geht dieses prozesses weiter
dass die mischungen auseinanderfallen
und am ende hat man die vier elemente
getrennt also erde wasser luft feuer als
vier sperren die ineinander gerät ja
gemeint sind dann geht es alles
rückwärts dass die schmerzen wieder
zusammen
sind wahrscheinlich wieder tiere
menschen und so weiter und verschmelzen
bis sie wieder diese homogenes werde
welten super verrückt die ganze ist
wirklich eine steile theorie könnte man
sagen wir haben keine zeit die ganze
begründungen zu diskutieren was aber
interessant ist ist dass er auch eine
erklärung hat woher tiere kommen und
zwar durch ein natürliches verfahren wo
zuerst teile sich bilden und deine tiere
zusammen kommen und an dass für diese
theorie wird war von harten ist
gesprochen doch kritisiert und ich hab
ein zitat dass es das an gebe die die
wörter von einem paradies der erde
entschlossen viele köpfe ohne halse
nackte arme hirten hin und her sondern
sondern schultern und augen allein
schweifen um herr der stirn war da heißt
das wissen viele geschöpfe hervor mit
doppelten gesicht und doppelter brust
geschöpfe von männern hinter enten
ochsen tauchten auf andere umgekehrt
männer lieber mit ochsen paar köpfen
mitgeschöpfe hier männer dort frauen
gestaltet mit beschatten schamp liedern
versehen
also das heißt getrennte augen rollen
hin und her schulter ohne arme waren wir
ohne schulter dann kommen sie zusammen
in bilden furchtbare gestalter wie
männern mit osten köpfe und so weiter
oder umgekehrt
und was interessant ist ist dass er sagt
dass die nicht
mischungen ausgestorben sind weiß ich
nicht pflanzen konnten
manchmal wird das als eine art
revolution ins leere
das brautpaar bezeichnet was ich da
nichts fähige oder nicht passende tiere
aussterben das klingt ein bisschen wie
da bin ich würde aber sagen dass das
eher ein gutes beispiel ist für punkt 3
das ist ein punkt ist dass die die
richtige tiere sind die tiere die
harmonisch zusammen gebaut sind wenn ich
diese zusagen gegen die natur
zusammengepresste ochsen männer sind
sondern ochsen oder menschen irgendwie
theologisch ist alles so wie es sein
soll wenn die tiere hatten entstehen die
wir kennen
man könnt ihr was sagen dass die tiere
hatten die überleben sind die die
ästhetisch wichtig sind wurde die
passend sind und dass die tatsache dass
sie fortpflanzen können
das ist nur ein zeichen dafür dass sie
passen sind okay letztlich wollte ich in
den letzten 15 minuten platon
besteuerten der natürlich sei diese
theorien und ideen aus den postkarten
kennt und aufnimmt warum ist eine eigene
theorien vorzuschlagen
unter denen ist die lehre der zweiten
liga zion
das kommt in bergen dialogen vor zum
beispiel indem feiern auch im team aus
und hier ist es wirklich klar dass die
dass die richtige auslegung der
wiedergeburt werde für platon ist die
die erwähnt haben die mit strafe zu tun
hat strafe und belohnung nichts
sie muss durch alle taten gehen um alles
zu erfahren sondern ich muss die ich
werde zum beispiel wolf weil ich ein
vielfraß war oder ob es zum beispiel
indem feiern das ist leider an einen 80
bis zu 1 8 hilfe über wissen wollen wie
das ist sagt sorgte thies natürlich
werden die zellen der schlechten
menschen in einen von solchen sitten
gebunden deren sie wären sie sich
befleißigt hatten im leben die sich ohne
alle schalter volle rey und das über
muss entrümpelt fleißigsten solche
begeben sich wollen natürlich in hesel
nun englisch arten von tieren die aber
ungerechtigkeit herrschsucht und
überhaupt vollzogen die sie dagegen in
die verschiedenen geschichte der wölfe
habe ich dir und geier und dann sagt er
dass die allgemeine und bürgerliche tun
die die allgemeine bürgerliche tugenden
nach gesteckt haben werden bienen oder
wissen oder ameisen oder wenn sie glück
haben sogar menschen ähnlicher weise
können wir im team - das ist ein dialog
der eigentlich ein monolog ist von einem
philosoph namens team aus wo er platt
und kosmologie vorstellt und am ende
erklärte wie die seelen durch die
verschiedene tierarten dann dort gehen
aber immer war er als strafe und sagt
dass die an
die menschen gesundheit die menschen die
feiern werden frauen die die unschuldig
waren aber ein bisschen dumm werden
vögel und die die ganz blöd von werden
werden werden vierbeinige menschen
vierbeinige tiere weil sie vorgezogen
werden in richtung erde bald anstatt
hoch zu denken haben sie niedrig gedacht
und deswegen im paten eigenen sie nach
vorne bis sie vierbeiner werden und die
blödeste männer werden sich die blödeste
menschen die blödesten männer gefangen
als männer an und werden dafür bestraft
weil dass wir nun nicht gelebt haben
dadurch dass wir frauen oder vögel an
tieren oder fische werden
das ist natürlich nicht sehr erfreulich
man soll auch aber dazu sagen dass es
manchmal bei platten komplizierter ist
diese wieder übers leere zum beispiel in
dem letzten buch der polit er habe ein
miethaus wo wir eine erzählung bekommen
dass die szenen ihr nächstes leben
aussuchen dürfen und dass wir in diesen
lägen philosophie vertreiben sollen
damit wir diese wahl des nächsten leben
gut machen und in dieser erzählung kommt
es vor dass manche markets allen die das
letzte mal menschen wählen wieder als
tier gebäuden zu werden zb weil sie was
gegen andere menschen haben weil sie so
schlecht behandelt wurden seien ajax
kommt voran er will tear werden war die
menschen ihm ungerecht verhandelt haben
glaube er wird ein löwe
jetzt entsteht natürlich die frage wie
ernst wird das alles nehmen sollen also
offensichtlich den er eine verbindung zu
dieser früheren politischen theorie des
wiedergeburt schlagen aber können wir
das mit zusammen mit seiner
philosophischen ansichten verbinden
ich würde sagen ja klar weil wenn wir an
die zellen terry von platon denken das
was einfällt ist dass er ein
zum beispiel indem weiter und das ist
wahrscheinlich das beste beispiel und
das ist auch ein dialog wo dieses ist
boll die st
diese videos sehr vorkommt da will
platon sagen und dass die seele und
körperlich ist dass die zelle abend den
tod des körpers überleben kann und
einfach weiter existieren kann
er hat auch diese wieder erinnerungs
lehre für erkenntnis oder wissen dass
wir das was wir wissen nennen ist
eigentlich erinnerung von den
erfahrungen die wir gemacht haben als
die zelle von dem körper getrennt gelebt
hat und die formen oder ideen gesehen
hat und so weiter also haben
kurzum die platonische sehr gute
körperliche seele die unabhängig von den
körper ist und über leben kann wenn man
das glaubt dann haben wir mindestens
einen riesenschritt in richtung einer
wiedergeburt wäre genommen weil es
mindestens möglich ist dass die eine
dieselbe zelle
zuerst mensch sein kann dann hier dann
wieder mensch oder ein tier als dann
eine andere tierart usw
weil es für die seele zufällig ist
welchen körper sie hat werden zum
beispiel als ort ließ sagen würde
nein die zelle ist die form des körpers
und deswegen ist es unvorstellbar dass
einige eine tier seele eine mensch
stelle werden könnte über das sind zwei
verschiedene arten von korn
also von daher würde ich das eigentlich
erst nehmen und diese mythen über h
wiedergeburt mindestens als kompatibel
mit seiner philosophischen sehen
trotzdem könnte man verschiedene fragen
stellen die er eigentlich nicht
beantwortet zum beispiel wenn eine
derselbe seele zuerst wert ist und dann
mensch und dann otte oder was auch immer
oder wenn diese szene in diesem körper
in meinem jetzigen körper zum beispiel
denken kann und philosophieren kann
wieso kann die seele das nicht machen
wenn diese lässt sich in einem pferd
befindet vor allem weil die seele es
scheint nicht dass der körper die seele
beeinflusst sondern kontrolliert die
seele den körper
das ist sogar ein argument in den
weiteren für die unsterblichkeit und
unabhängigkeit der seele dass die seele
er den körper steuert als dass der
körper die seele beeinflusst also wieso
dann verliert die serie all diese
fähigkeiten die wir mit der menschlichen
natur verbinden sobald sie sehr lässig
in einem tier körper befindet das ist
ein brezn dann was platon nicht löst
eine idee wäre vielleicht dass diese
fähigkeiten immer noch da sind und der
zelle gehören die seele kann sie aber
nicht zeiten ja vielleicht denkt sogar
die serie die ganze zeit
aber und meine katze er habe eine katze
namens pappe und das würde heißen pepper
vielleicht philosophiert sie dem ganzen
tage und das kann ich nur nicht sehen
weil wie ich sollte ich das sehe ich
will kann nur sein dass sie unbedingt
fressen will und zwar jetzt und das
werden wir noch mal besprechen wenn wir
keine ferien sprechen dann letztlich
wollte ich auch erwähnen
unter punkt 3 dass platon diese neigung
die hier schon bei dem vorfall
beobachtet haben
vergleiche zwischen den kopf ganzen
kosmos und einem lebewesen gerade zu
machen diese neigung kommt bei platon
übrigens an die geschichte mit
empedokles dass die welt wie eines werde
anfängt dann wird tipp dann wird
komplizierter bis das vier elemente dann
bildet das könnte man auch irgendwie
organisch auslegen dass es irgendwie wie
die entwicklung eines tier ist die dann
ein tier das älter wird oder durch ein
natürliches verhalten prozess geht
vielleicht aber bei platon ist es sehr
sehr deutlich dass der kosmos ein
lebewesen hast das sagt er ausdrücklich
in dem team aus erstens haben last der
team aus der sprecher sagen dass gott
der den orkus der der hand der göttliche
handwerker der den kosmos baut oder
gestaltet und es schafft macht ihn als
abbild der form oder der platonischen
idee des lebewesens
es gibt eine form des lebewesens und der
kosmos ist das perfekteste abbild davon
genau wie wir auch abbilder dieses
dieser form sind und wenn das nicht
deutlich genug werde sagte er auch dass
die ganze dass der ganze
cosmos das ganze universum hat eine
seele die sogenannte weltserie
die haben den körper des kosmos
durchdringt und irgendwie steuert genau
wie bundesräte seele unsere unseren
körper steuert in der ersten linie was
er hier erkennen will ist himmlische
bewegung was die die kreisförmige
bewegung der himmelskörper körper um
unsere erde wie er das sie versteht sind
[Musik]
entstehen dadurch dass die seele denn
die himmelskörper in bewegung setzt im
allgemeinen versteht er die seele nicht
nur als prinzip des denkens sondern auch
als prinzip der bewegung also
fortbewegung und die die erste fähigkeit
die der kosmos wegen der welt celle hat
ist eben kreisförmige bewegungen
deswegen sagt der eigentlichen dem
letzten satz des ganzen dialogs sagte
team aus nachdem der die welt in der
obigen weise mit sterblichen und
unsterblichen belegten wesen ausgerüstet
und erfüllt worden ist die soll satz zu
einem sichtbaren besen dieser art
geworden also das universum ist ein
lebewesen ein tier das ende der tiere
einschließt wie wir und auch natürlich
alle tiere halten und diese idee werden
wir später gespürt dass müssen wissen
dass sie festhalten weil ich werde diese
theorie der welt zähle besprechen wenn
wir latein mittelalter erreichen und das
geschieht erst um weihnachten oder so
also wir müssen das im kopf bis dann
halten aber ich werde sie natürlich
daran
ok jetzt haben wir ein paar minuten
verklagen falls jemand fragen hat